>>> BREAKI NEWS, NEW SATELLITE
IMAGES SHOW THE 40-MILE LONG
CONVOY NORTH OF KYIV HAS
DISPERSED AND REDEPLOYED, MOVING
INTO FIELDS AND WOODED AREAS.
THE PROBLEM IS WHAT TO MAKE OF
IT.
WE TURN TO OUR FORMER CIA
DIRECTOR, GENERAL PETRAEUS.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THESE
NEW IMAGES?
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF WHAT THAT
CONVOY IS DOING?
>> IT IS REALLY JUST ADHERING TO
NORMAL STANDARDS THAT THEY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN ADHERING TO ALL
ALONG.
OUR SOLDIERS TRAINED THAT WHEN
YOU STOP, YOU DON'T STAY ON A
ROAD.
YOU DON'T STAY VISIBLE TO
ANYTHING FROM THE AIR.
YOU HOLD UNDER COVER.
WHETHER IT IS TREES OR WHATEVER
YOU CAN FIND.
YOU CERTAINLY DON'T STAY AGAIN,
EXPOSED.
THE WAY THAT THEY WERE FOR SO
MANY DAYS.
IT WAS REALLY AGAIN, STAGGERING
THAT THAT HAPPENED.
AND YOU SAW IN THE FOOTAGE THAT
YOU'RE SHOWING RIGHT NOW, IN
FACT, ANOTHER CASE WHERE AN
ARMORED BATTALION IS CAUGHT IN
THE OPEN.
APPARENTLY BY A DRONE THAT
APPEARS TO BE FILMING THIS.
MAY HAVE BEEN DIRECTING THE FIRE
AS WELL.
AND AGAIN, IT IS SORT OF
UNCONSCIONABLE THAT THIS COULD
HAPPEN.
THEY'RE ALSO BUNCHED TOGETHER.
WOULD YOU ALWAYS WANT TO STAY
MUCH FARTHER APART THAN THAT.
SO AGAIN, THESE ARE BASIC
STANDARDS THAT CLEARLY HAVE NOT
BEEN ESTABLISHED AND THEY'RE
CERTAINLY NOT PERFORMING IN
ACCORDANCE WITH WHAT NORMAL
STANDARDS WOULD BE FOR OUR
FORCES.
>> CLARISSA WARD WAS TALKING
ABOUT THE DEFENSES WHICH ARE
EVERYWHERE IN A CITY LIKE KYIV,
ON EVERY STREET, HEDGE HOGS,
THEY HIT ON SIDES OF ROADS.
AND WE KNOW THAT THE MOLOTOV
COCKTAILS THAT HAVE BEEN
DISPERSED.
GIVEN THAT, IS IT LIKELY THAT
RUSSIAN FORCES WILL JUST TRY TO
LEVEL THESE CITIES BEFORE
ACTUALLY GOING IN?
BECAUSE YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT IT
BEFORE.
THEY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TROOPS TO
REALLY ADEQUATELY UNDERTAKE
BLOCK BY BLOCK, URBAN COMBAT.
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
AS WE DISCUSSED BEFORE, IT IS
ALSO INCREDIBLY PHYSICALLY
DEMANDING AND MENTALLY DRAINING.
I'M STARTING TO THINK THEY WON'T
EVEN BE ABLE TO ENCIRCLE KYIV.
AGAIN, THAT BLOW STRUCK AGAINST
AN ARMORED REGIMENT.
THE RUSSIAN IN THAT CLIP THAT
YOU PLAYED EARLIER IS ALSO
REPORTING THAT THE REGIMENTAL
COMMANDER WAS KILLED.
THAT'S AN STRARD BLOW.
YOU ADD THAT TO THE OTHER
CASUALTIES.
THE OTHER LOSSES OF ARMOR AND
PERSONNEL AND SO FORTH.
YOU JUST CAN'T KEEP SUSTAINING
THAT KIND OF LOSS.
THE COLUMN FROM THE EAST IN
PARTICULAR, WHERE THIS WAS
AMBUSHED IS SO LONG AND SO
VULNERABLE GIVEN THE LOGISTICAL
LINES REQUIRED FOR THAT THAT
THERE IS NO WAY, I DON'T THINK,
THAT THEY'LL BE ABLE TO SUSTAIN
THEIR FORCES COMING FROM THAT
DIRECTION WHICH MEANS THEY
PROBABLY CAN'T GET AROUND TO THE
SOUTH AND REALLY CLOSE THE CITY
OFF WHICH COULD BE VERY, VERY
GOOD NEWS FOR KYIV IN THE SENSE
THAT AT LEAST IT COULD BE
REPLIED, EVEN IF THE RUSSIANS
TRY TO LAY SIEGE TO IT FROM THE
OTHER DIRECTIONS.
FROM THE NORTH AND TO A DEGREE,
FROM THE WEST.
AS YOU NOTED, WHAT THEY WILL DO
IS BACK OFF.
THEY'RE JUST GOING TO RUBBLE THE
CITY BLOCK BY BLOCK.
BUT NORMALLY, YOU WOULD NEED TO
MOVE IN AT LEAST TO HAVE
OBSERVATION.
FAIR.
ALTHOUGH THEY'VE CERTAINLY DONE
LOTS OF INDISCRIMINATE FIRE AS
WE'VE SEEN INTO MARIUPOL IN
PARTICULAR.
THAT SITUATION, I THINK, HAS TO
BE THE ONE REALLY EATING AT THE
PRESIDENT.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY, THE
MINISTER OF DEFENSE, CHIEF OF
GENERAL STAFF, TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT ANY WAY THEY COULD TO LIFT
THAT SIEGE, TO BREAK INTO
MARIUPOL, TO RESTORE THE BASIC
SERVICES AND SO FORTH.
IT IS PRETTY CLEAR, THEY JUST
DON'T HAVE THE RESERVES TO DO
THAT.
EVEN THOUGH THEY'VE STOPPED THE
RUSSIANS AROUND KHARKIV AND THE
THRUST THAT WAS DISCUSSED
EARLIER FROM CRIMEA TOWARD
ODESA.
IT IS STOPPED IN A CITY CALLED
MYKOLAIV WHERE THE GENERAL IS
TURNING INTO A REAL HERO.
IF THEY'VE RIGGED THE BRIDGES
FOR DESTRUCTION, IF THEY CAN'T
GET ACROSS THAT RIVER, THEY HAVE
TO GO MUCH FARTHER TO THE NORTH
AND THEN DOWN TO THE SOUTHWEST
TO ODESA.
AND AGAIN, THERE IS NO WAY
THEY'LL MAINTAIN THOSE
LOGISTICAL LINES.
>> FOR MARIUPOL, FOR THEM TO
TAKE IT, JUST FOR FUTURE
REASONS, THEY'VE ALLEGEDLY,
ACCORDING TO U.S. SENIOR DEFENSE
OFFICIALS, THEY'VE ENCIRCLED IT.
WOULD IT BE POSSIBLE, IS THE
SAME THING AT PLAY THERE TO
ACTUALLY OCCUPY THAT CITY, TO
MOVE IN?
THAT IT WOULD BE EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT FOR RUSSIAN FORCES?
IT IS A.
SMALLER CITY THAN KYIV.
>> I THINK WHAT THEY'RE TRYING
TO DO THERE IS LITERALLY STARVE
IT INTO SUBMISSION.
THE WATER IS CUT OFF.
THE POWER IS CUT OFF.
VERY, VERY DESPERATE SITUATION.
YOU SHOWED HOW BODIES, YOU CAN'T
EVEN DO PROPER BURIALS FOR
BODIES AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
WHAT THEY'LL DO IS STARVE IT
UNTIL IT SUBMITS.
UNTIL THE OFFICIALS THERE IN
CHARGE SURRENDER.
I ASSUME, IS THEIR HOPE.
THAT WOULD THEN ENABLE THEM TO
COMPLETE THE LAND BRIDGE FROM
CRIMEA TO THE DONBAS, THE AREA
IN THE SOUTHEAST.
THEY WILL HAVE DENIED THAT
ENTIRE PORTION OF THE COAST TO
UKRAINE.
SO IT IS REALLY A MATTER OF TIME
UNLESS THE UKRAINIANS CAN FIGURE
OUT HOW TO BREAK THAT SIEGE
SOMEHOW.
AND GET SUPPLIES IN, RESTORE
BASIC SERVICES AND SO FORTH.
I'M SURE THAT IS ISSUE THAT IS
REALLY BEDEVILLING THEM.
AND COMMANDERS ALLOCATE
SHORTAGES.
YOU NEVER HAVE ENOUGH OF
ANYTHING.
SO WHAT THEY MAY HAVE TO DO IS
REALLOCATE SOME FORCES FROM
SOMEWHERE ELSEWHERE THEY SEEM TO
BE DOING BETTER THAN PERHAPS
THEY FEARED WHEN THE PLAN WAS
DEVELOPED INITIALLY TO TRY TO
GET DOWN THERE.
OTHERWISE, AT SOME POINT IN
TIME, THAT WILL BECOME THE FIRST
MAJOR CITY IN UKRAINE TO FOLLOW.
AND IT WILL ALSO FREE UP THE
FORCES THAT ARE ENCIRCLING IT TO
SOME DEGREE AT LEAST, AND THAT
COULD BE A PROBLEM ELSEWHERE AS
WELL.
>> JUST ONE FINAL QUESTION.
JUST FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF A
GUERRILLA FATE, HOW EFFECTIVE IS
A MOLOTOV COCKTAIL?
CLEARLY THERE ARE A LOT OF THEM
AROUND THEM.
I KNOW THEY HAVE ACCEL RANT
INSIDE TO MAKE THEM STICKIER.
ONE PERSON WAS SAYING AGAINST A
TANK, THEY ARE CLOSED SYSTEMS
THAT DO HAVE AN AIR I AM TAKE.
IF YOU THROW IT AT THE AIR
INTAKE, IT SMOKES OUT THE PEOPLE
INSIDE THE TANK.
IS THAT TRUE?
>> WELL, AGAIN, WE HAVE SOME
VIEWS ABOUT THE RUSSIANS SYSTEMS
THAT SO FAR ARE NOT PROVING
TRUE.
THEY'RE MUCH LESS WELL EQUIPPED
THAN WE BELIEVED.
TO BELIEVE THEY WORKED AS
ADVERTISED PROBABLY IS WORTH AT
LEAST ASKING ABOUT.
WHAT YOU REALLY NEED TO DO IS
GET THE HATCHES TO POP SOMEHOW.
THE NORMAL WAY THAT'S DONE, AND
EVEN OUR TANKS GOING INTO
BAGHDAD, THEY COULD GET SWARMED.
IF THE INFANTRY IS NOT AROUND
THEM, YOU COULD HAVE A PROBLEM
AT SOME POINT IN TIME.
WHAT YOU REALLY WANT TO DO IS
GET THE MOLOTOV COCKTAIL INSIDE
THE TANK TURRET.
TO DO THAT, YOU HAVE TO GET THEM
OFF THOSE HATCHES.
AND THERE ARE VARIOUS WAYS.
YOU CAN ALSO PERHAPS, DEPENDING
ON HOW EXPOSED THE ENGINE GRATES
ARE, THERE ARE PLACES THAT ARE
FLAMMABLE.
AGAINST THIN SKINNED VEHICLES,
THEY CAN BE DEVASTATING AND
THERE ARE OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES IN
WHICH THEY CAN BE REVALUABLE.
WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO IS AS WE'VE
SEEN, RUSSIANS HAVE BEEN VERY
POOR AT ACHIEVING COMBINED ARMS
EFFECTS.
THEY SENT TANKS ALONE WITHOUT
INFANTRY.
INFANTRY ALONE WITHOUT TANKS.
NO ENGINEERS AROUND THEM TO HELP
WITH OBSTACLES AND SO FORTH, AND
NOT SUPPORTED BY ARTILLERY
CREEPING ALONG IN FRONT, THE
FIRE IN FRONT OF THEM AS
REQUIRED.
SO AGAIN, THEY COULD BE VERY
VULNERABLE.
OR AS YOU SAW, IF THEY'RE OUT IN
THE OPEN, AND EITHER GROUND OR
AIR OBSERVATION CAN IDENTIFY
THEM, THEN THE RIGHT FORCES CAN
BE BROUGHT TO BEAR